parking violations in New York city so
New York City Council introduces Bill
requiring richer people to pay more for
violations like parking tickets double
parking than the average person meaning
if you make more money you pay more and
California is doing a similar thing as
well there let me read this story so
this this kind of this to me is strange
to just think about it say hey how much
money you make last year well listen
your ticket's going to be 600 instead of
300 what a wild situation in New York so
here we go a new bill proposed by New
York City Council would introduce a
pilot program to scale civil fines such
as parking tickets based on a person's
income making richer people pay more for
these fines proponents of the bill argue
that scaling the fees would encourage
more people to pay and ensure that the
penalties are fair and proportionate to
person's ability to pay the independent
budget office found that New York City
is owed more than two billion dollars in
unpaid fines from just the last five
years the bill has to survive a hearing
in the council to be reviewed by mayor
Eric Adams once it's introduced similar
programs exist in a handful of cities
around the country and in Europe where
Technologies used to look up taxpayers
income to calculate fines and by the way
California is doing a similar thing
proposed proposed proposing charging
customers based on how much money they
make when it comes down to their
electrical bill so if you make 180 or
more you could pay 85 or more for your
electricity Tom what are your thoughts
on the story uh folks when you hear when
you hear them talking about social
security and you hear the following
words means test so when you see the
riots that were going on in France or 10
years ago they had a thing called
austerity which was riots about people
had we're told they'd be retiring at a
later age before they get their
government pension the pension would be
smaller if you don't have to be
Economist to remember all that happened
10 years ago in Greece and it's
happening right now in France and you'll
hear Social Security means test means if
you have the means to pay you're going
to get less social security or you're
going to have to pay more for Medicare
services so that has been the kernel the
seed that is behind this and now this is
just expanding by the way the reason I'm
doing this is because our government is
we can say bro can we keep raising the
debt limit which is nothing more than
raising the credit card limit on the
United States of America it's from from
unpayable to damn unpayable
and so what New York is doing is just
picking up the same thing they say hey
the United States is broke and some of
you when you are old enough to get
Social Security if you can afford to pay
for other things you're going to pay for
them and you're not going to give you
the Social Security because we're broke
and we're going to give it to the middle
class and these and and people with
lesser capabilities but you people that
are wealthy it'll be a means test you
have the means to pay then you don't get
Social Security or Medicare cost you
more and now they're bringing it over to
parking tickets saying hey wait you know
we got all this uh we have all this
technology what if we find out if the
guy hey he's a 400 000 year banker and
he parked his Mercedes S-Class here and
the meter ran out maybe that should be a
hundred dollars for him not twenty five
dollars and that's what they're doing
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
socialism can I can I ask you a question
though it's okay
so liberals argument I'll give you the
other side of the argument you ready
well who came up with progress wrong who
came up with I'm sorry I jumped the gun
who came up with Progressive taxes who
came up with Progressive taxes
which president which president
who was big on we should we should tax
you know well Ronald Reagan even said we
should tax you know have progressive tax
and we should do this and we should do
that so even your own president was for
progressive tax your your god of
presidents Ronald Reagan proposed this
why shouldn't we have progressive tax
when it comes down to parking fees
electrical bills all these other things
what do you say to that argument well I
didn't support that policy by Ronald
Reagan so I think the response is that
that was wrong you know conservatives
have made mistakes many times you have
to be willing to call out your own side
I mean this is this is just standard
penalization of wealth I don't
understand why anyone who's successful
would live in a place like New York I
cannot imagine why someone like you for
example who's been wildly successful in
business made a bunch of money I can't
imagine why unless you had to for some
business reason you know I lived in New
York City for a long time because I
worked you know in media you had to be
there it was horrible but why would
someone elect to live in a place that
outright comes front and center and
penalizes you for wealth penalizes you
for success as there's a separate set of
standards for you the reason they're
doing this is because there's bolt loads
of people that you know you open up
their glove compartment in their car and
all that comes out are just parking
tickets that have been unpaid and most
of those people are lower income and you
know what they say they say Well they're
not going to come for me because there's
this sense in places like New York City
that they won't come for the so-called
little guy but if you're making you know
400 500 600 000 a year you're successful
oh how dare you so it's just to me
standard wealth penalization in in in
woke you know Progressive which are you
know basically regressive bastions so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]